endorsed by one government Body censured
by another on the same day competing
announcements that add to the confusion
following the controversial presidential
runoff election in Guatemala nine days
ago
the Supreme electoral tribunal has
already officially ratified the results
of August 20. therefore Dr Karen Herrera
is vice president-elect and I'm
president-elect this is an irrefutable
fact apart from that there is the
suspension of the seed movement that has
no relation with our ratification
despite the resounding result in the
runoff the impact of his political party
being suspended is unclear
the suspension is unlikely to affect his
swearing-in due in January but it could
weaken his rule before it begins
extremely alarming because today they
are trying to confuse us with news with
disinformation by generating fear and
psychological warfare honestly I am fed
up with the system and fed up that they
are playing with the will of the people
in this way
aravalo's election opponent former first
lady Sandra Torres accuses him of voter
fraud something the Electoral registry
that banned his party is investigating
aquing president Alejandro giamatte has
so far not publicly commented
our revolo the son of a former Diplomat
is an unlikely winner his Ballot Box
success as an anti-corruption campaigner
represents a threat to the country's
Elite and the status quo
aravalo's Progressive campaign resonated
with Guatemalans who were tired of
corruption and hungry for change
Zen basavi Al Jazeera
let's get more on this we can speak to
Javier faje he's an analyst specializing
in Latin American Affairs he joins us
now from London thank you for your time
now as I understand it there was an
attempt to suspend the seed party during
the election itself but the motion was
blocked by a high court so what's
changed now
basically what happened was that the
Supreme electoral tribunal has already
ratified Mr arebalo's Victory and he's a
new president-elect a department of the
Electoral tribunal called The Citizen
registry suspended the legal status of
his party semiya or seed uh you know and
just minutes before the announcements of
his victory was made yesterday so there
was like like two departments of the
same institution fighting one another uh
the support from the moment the Supreme
Court the Supreme tribunal the Electoral
tribunal the class Mr Rivera winner
there's nothing anyone can do about that
the suspension of the legal status of
this party may cause some legal trouble
in the future but they cannot stop Mr
Arevalo from being sworn in as president
of Guatemala we have to understand that
the people who've been involved in
trying to suspend this party the sustain
its illegal status are people who are
already accused of corruption by United
States who a judge called Freddie
orellana uh the nouns Mr uh arrival of
party as fraudulent signature signatures
that are required to be registered as a
political partyana is in the list of
corrupt officials sanctioned by United
States this uh denunciation by this
judge was sent to the special
prosecutor's office against impunity led
by somebody called Raphael kuruchiche
and not a judge been sanctioned for
corruption by the United States right so
these cities registry actually suspended
based on these accusations the legal
status of semia but that will not stop
Mr Rivera from becoming president okay
so just to be clear he doesn't have to
appeal this in any way he is due to take
office I understand on the 14th of
January that is likely to go ahead as
planned
yes but he has to he has to appeal he
will because this this suspension of the
legal status of the media may cause some
trouble throughout the transition from
the outgoing government to the new
government they might be they might
prevent certain people within the team
that will lead the transition from doing
their work and that is what could create
a lot of problems but also it's going to
create political uncertainty in a
country which with the election of
miserable wants to get out of this
uncertainty we mustn't forget it's an
anti-corruption candidate and and he's
received from death threats to such an
extended in January the inter-american
commission of Human Rights demanded
protection for him to prevent uh
something happening to him as it
happened in Ecuador with Fernando the
anti-corruption presidential candidate
was assassinated on the 9th of August so
we're talking about a corrupt Elite
according to all the analysts including
the UN International commission against
impunity who are trying to prevent this
and corruption president from taking
office in January next year that is
basically what is looking what is
happening at the moment in Guatemala
what seems incredible is that this is
allowed to happen because the majority
of people from what I understand support
a revolo
oh yes what's happening is that the
establishment judge Fredo Ariana
the judge Rafael kuruchice the Attorney
General Consuelo porras who raided the
offices of the Tribune of the Electoral
tribunal who is also in the list of 10
corrupt officials sanctioned by the
United States they constitute the
current Elite the current establishment
political and judicial establishment in
Guatemala they have the power which
means that they are trying to prevent an
anti-corruption president from taking
office because they fear that the
investigation may lead to more
prosecution against these people so this
is we're talking about a a system which
happening in place for the last at least
10 years with all these alleged these
corrupt officials have the power in
Guatemala and they are trying to prevent
this area from taking office and of
course in the government Alejandra
jamate which is the outgoing president
has been accused also of corruption to
such an extent that International
commission against impunity which was
expelled from Guatemala in 2019 has
clearly accused the current government
and many members of the government and
the Judiciary of impartial corruption so
this is looks based on the analysis a
corrupt Elite which are afraid an
anti-corruption president takes off his
understanding investigating right got
him okay good to speak to you Javier
fare analyst specializing in Latin
American Affairs
thank you